good morning Hank it's Tuesday today's
video is like the ninth rib on my right
side it comes to you in two parts part
one my rib so anka broke my rib
celebrating my 39th birthday last week
it's pretty uncomfortable like
activities that have suddenly become
extremely painful include sitting down
standing up laughing and also breathing
also for the record filming YouTube
videos is not very comfortable I really
can't recommend any facet of the broken
rib thing this happens to be a
particularly inconvenient time to have a
broken rib partly for reasons that will
become clear in a couple weeks and
partly because the broken rib has
coincided with a previously scheduled
midwife reflection so I've been
middle-aged for a while in the sense
that if you were to double my current
age it would be a perfectly respectable
human lifespan but I've only recently
begun to feel middle-aged in the sense
of being you know acutely aware that I
am NOT as young as I used to be in fact
up until recently I felt much better
than I did 10 or 20 years ago largely
because when I was younger I treated my
body terribly like I smoked cigarettes
and steadfastly refused to exercise I
remember once when I was at boarding
school I was probably about 16 I ate
nothing but Nacho Cheese Doritos and
drank nothing but Mountain Dew for eight
days straight it was like a demented
exploration of how poorly one can treat
one's body before developing scurvy in
those days I thought of my body is like
a burden that I was biologically
required to lug around I thought living
inside a body was the price I had to pay
for consciousness and I bought into the
idea that the body wasn't just separate
from the mind but somehow the opposite
of the mind I imagined my body as an
adversary like I was this thinking
feeling capitalized noun and my body was
a lowercase animal that needed to be
placated so I could go on thinking and
feeling this is a seductive line of
reasoning but ultimately a flawed one of
course because there is no distinct line
between body and mind also when I
started treating my body better I quit
smoking in 2002 ran a mile for the first
time since childhood in 2005 I found
that I got better at the activities I'm
most associated with my mind reading and
writing so anyway having treated my body
terribly when I was an adolescent and
somewhat less terribly in my 30s I've
been able to feel relatively young for
the last decade or so but now that time
has passed I am old and can no longer in
hair without pain and there really isn't
any moral to this story except I guess
one your body is a temple do not
with Doritos and also to do not fill it
with beer on your 39th birthday or else
you'll hurt yourself all right moving on
part two the future so Hank it's been
almost five years since my book The
Fault in Our Stars was published lots of
awesome has happened in my life in those
five years crash course happened as did
the art assignment alice happened some
movies happened but one thing that did
not happen
is that I have not published a new book
so I have decided to kind of clear my
schedule for the next several months as
I try to finish a draft of my new story
meaning that over the next ten months or
so I will only be making three public
appearances which are as follows one on
October 14th and 15th I will be at
nerdcon stories in Minneapolis while
there I'll be speaking on a few panels
recording a live edition of our podcast
and also talking a little bit about
mental illness and creativity - in 2017
On February 25th and 26th I will be at
nerdcon nerdfighteria in Boston I'm very
excited about that and three on May
third of 2017 I will be in Cleveland
giving a speech on the topic of I don't
know what yet because that seems very
far away ticket info for all those
events can be found in the doobly-doo
below I'm sorry I'm not traveling more
in the coming months but I really really
really want to finish a draft of the new
book so thanks for understanding and I
hope to see lots of you in Minneapolis
Boston or Cleveland Hank the FDNY BR I
will see you on Friday